ok so you guys I'm back I timed it and
it has taken me four hours to figure out
what I was supposed to be doing here but
only with the help of a friend so I've
gotten a kind of vague tip of what I
need to be doing and the first thing of
how I need to do it so i'm pretty sure
that we're still going to spend a lot of
time being really really confused here
but you know I've been pointed in the
right direction after just not being
able to figure out what I need to do so
the first thing that I have to do just
get another what now there we go who'd
have thought right I do need two dead
ones and then I need to get bread I
didn't even know you could interact with
this you know what oh maybe I can't give
me the bread that's another boom done
away ok let's put this away done nothing
no item pencil ok then Trevor it really
didn't get this a man we got this right
now we have bread I think I'm entitled
to all those the tips that I was given
because how would I know that and then I
know that I need to go to the lobby so
once i get to the lobby there should be
a new room and by the time i get there i
don't know what i have to do so what
kind of as far as I can be I'll try my
very best to not make this take
that wouldn't know what that wouldn't be
a very good use of this special so ok
here we go there we go all right
apparently you can't open doors when
you're holding bread ok there we go so
this is where that angry demon guy was
before and I have to come in here and I
assume do something with the be a pipe
or something away twisted I have no idea
ok that's me oh no you and one of these
was the victim up already um ok let's
nothing right that's 30 mom's animals
okay I know why you would but let's can
we try that yeah that does make sense ok
so let's want and then the other one the
other one yes
okay so we've just I don't know why I
did that what do I maybe I go to that
thing outside that I saw before and
trying to put them in there why do I
have a breadstick I have no idea okay I
don't know what you would use a
breadstick for a breadstick and two
balloons filled with stuff that makes
phone let's just try it out I guess this
is just so much more complicated that it
should be okay mmm hello that's bread
stick in there let's try that I'm not
picking that I don't like the way that I
is looking at me it's takeout okay that
wouldn't be a very good use of this
special ceremonial brain hey red all
right Fred up I don't really want to do
that no okay then I'm gonna try and
maybe put them
back in the pipe upstairs look all right
here we go and see if that's right so I
don't know why I'm trying to screw this
up like I did genuinely seem angry and I
didn't seem to want him to be seem to
want him to be angry so I don't know
really want to know that and put it away
just nothing okay this is crazy so we're
gonna find one of the things that they
put beer in and we're going to jam some
stuff into it and I hope that that's the
right thing to do maybe I should climb
into the boss's office again I'll put
the minions so you get some trumpet for
it is this the boss's office yes your
new boo Hey well this is nice well at
least you're not hitting the big Kelly
so how'd you make out of the poisoning
well let's just say that sister calabaza
has a secret passion
for trains you got a nun what hail from
the train on the number 9 dream
choo-choo little buddy that's the
premium thing say how did you score
yeah it's actually hey that reminds me
of this really all joke heard it um yeah
let's do that I want to punch you in the
mouth oh like I'm not looking at him at
Christmas party all over again well ah
screw this guy that's great we should do
this I was he sweating this even have
sweat glands he's a skeleton me Jim his
pipe yeah he's got a lock ha that's a
shame all right listen for my office it
is and then if that doesn't work we will
go to the boss's office and try that
again it's a so goddamn weird okay
let's give it a go and that one let's
try that yeah yes okay I don't know why
I'm doing that seems right so I'm gonna
put the other one now maybe no I'm not
supposed to surely I am come on so the
message she was full of nothing head I
fill it with something then not portable
oh this wild that one and give that a
try yeah yes oh he's just doing the same
thing supposed to get two worms
that doesn't sound good okay this seems
correct why did i do that i have no idea
ok back out I mean what do we do with
this breadstick maybe I can give it to
know I can keep the 20 10 don't know hmm
i guess i'll go back down bone maybe
servers down again oh this down girl is
that what I did yay ok so we'll go have
a look at that and then if I need to
we'll go back outside and put the bread
stick in the boss's room in his tube
assuming that it's also not locked this
doesn't make sense I have no idea why
I'm doing any of this stuff all right
no what no it wasn't this room oh my god
I'm so confused this way maybe we go
this way I have no idea oh here another
door let's give this a try this is new
uh-huh talk to him can't reach anybody
hi I'm not getting any messages is this
rumor down this is their idea of a joke
they think it's funny I'd like to jam
their tubes with my material see how
they're like that I definitely don't
condone it i'm not i'm not sure what
you're referring to hmm hey who would do
a terrible thing like this meets those
punks in the mail room they think this
baby is going to put them out of a job
and their right to discuss julius how
you get in there i squeezed out of all
of these tubes like a big see why do you
think i got in here through the dog just
like you right ok
I supposed to do laughter you're saying
the server is down is that it the server
is not down if it smoothly down now it's
just temporarily unavailable while I'm
doing some maintenance that's all I
think the minutes down so how long is it
gonna be down with a job like this you
can never tell probably hours or until
no one's around to see you sneak out
inch ever comes first
squeeze in there just for a sec are you
kidding this is a highly secured area no
one's allowed in here wait me what's so
special about you aye sir simon stopping
in spirit someone from the land of the
dead another spirit yeah yeah let me
guess who give me one purpose once one
desire fixing matic tube switchers no I
was created to run the elevators but
they put in those dang motion detectors
and put me out the world okay I really
think it's something else a happily it's
clean enough to run all right I'm just
fiddling around to be safe yepo gotta
cover my ass yes you do say Jackie Cathy
I got a lot of boobs to flush here hey
me too I'll let you go it's his butt
crack that achieve nothing I got nothing
from that conversation I'm supposed to
happen no no oh this is good he's on
fire you're trying to blow this joint
sky high that's a magnesium or about
fire extinguisher spray that on this
packing foam and we'll both be riding a
giant roman candle out of here what why
would they put something so it sounds
really ineffective yes they didn't
expect this room to be full of hazardous
waste right oh uh what am I supposed to
do with this
uh as a rule I never touch anything more
sophisticated and delicate than myself I
have no idea what's going on here
houdina I don't know why I blocked it
though
okay well I guess that's that then